goats are conquering empty streets in a
British village what a strange picture
to us humans who are used to only seeing
ourselves governing the world as soon as
we withdraw nature quickly takes over
like these monkeys in Thailand as well
could the corona crisis eventually be
good for the environment satellite
images seem to prove just that in Italy
where people have been living in
lockdown for weeks
traffic has nearly stops and nitrogen
dioxide levels have clearly dropped and
another study suggests that Germany
might even reach its climate goals as
the corona lockdown causes the economy
to produce much less co2 our factories
devoid of workers thousands of flights
cancelled empty streets because people
are working from home instead of driving
to the office global economic activity
has been put into an induced coma bad
for the world economy but from a climate
perspective the corona virus pandemic
it's not entirely negative environmental
activists might actually rejoice
measures have been implemented
immediately they're drastically cut
emissions emissions measures that
otherwise would have taken years to come
into effect images from space China's
air pollution shown in red shrunk
dramatically between December and March
thick smog has given way to blue skies
thanks to closed factories reduced
capacity power plants and fewer cars on
the roads
Beijing's residents have been enjoying
some unusually fresh spring air and
they're not alone the air in Europe is
better too depending on how long the
crisis goes on for the Agoura think tank
estimates that Germany's greenhouse gas
emissions could be 40 percent lower this
year than last
tourist hot spots are also enjoying some
respite
Venice normally bustling with over 20
million tourists each year is virtually
empty the water in its many canals
usually dull and murky as a result of
the many boats is suddenly clear
[Music]
aircrafts are responsible for around
seven percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions but the booming business is
currently very humble international
flights have been reduced to a minimum
German carrier Lufthansa for example has
cut ninety percent of its long distance
flights in many countries lockdowns are
set to continue for some time others are
on the threshold of theirs China however
is beginning to wind its economy back up
again and that raises the question when
the lockdowns end will it be business as
usual well will it joining me now is
added niranjan he's from our environment
desk
we just saw some of the positive effects
in inverted commas of this pandemic on
the environment so will we or should we
go back to business as usual we need to
go back to what we're doing before but
in a different way it's really difficult
to talk about silver linings or to kind
of celebrate these lockdowns because of
course we're in the middle of a pandemic
and this is a much more urgent crisis
than the climate crisis that we're also
living under you can understand people
celebrating this partially particularly
when we talk about air pollution now air
pollution is one of the world's most
deadly killers it claims more than 7
million lives each year and it shaves
off on average about three years of our
lives particularly for people living in
the global South in Africa and Asia now
what this means when we've got lockdowns
which have reduced pollution and we can
see partially in China and Italy is that
in the short term at least people are
able to breathe better the question is
how long can this be held on for and
once these lockdowns lift
how will the economy would be reshaped
in a way that doesn't lead just more
smoke more smog being produced
yeah rather puts things into perspective
actually
shut down also causes a drastic cut in
co2 emissions to a degree that Germany
might even reach its climate goals for
this year prematurely is that shut down
or a shot on of that magnitude what it
takes to reach climate targets it's one
way of reaching them but I think most
climate experts would say it's not a
particularly good way of doing so there
are clear solutions that would enable us
to reduce greenhouse gas gas emissions
and meet the climate targets countries
have agreed on in a way that doesn't
require people to stay locked in their
houses or to halt economic activity the
most obvious of these solutions is to
transition from fossil fuels to
renewable energy sources like wind and
solar power and on top of that change
how we consume food how we to reduce the
amount of for instance beef that's being
eaten that requires raising rainforests
and raising large numbers of cattle that
belch methane and other greenhouse gases
so the key point is really to from what
the climate expert is saying is to find
ways to reduce these emissions without
causing the harm to the economy to
humans that these lockdowns are
currently doing but do you think that
once the recovery period after kovat has
started do you think that fighting
climate change will go on the back
burner for a while I think we're already
seeing that happen and it's hard to
predict how that will play out once the
pandemic is over which will hopefully be
as soon as possible what we're going to
see this year for sure is climate
summits being canceled or postponed or I
mean potentially held over Skype and
video chats but a lot less effective is
a clearer answer we can see governments
have much bigger priorities to deal with
namely reducing the spread of the virus
and on top of that we also have the
issue of the kind of momentum behind
change being lost
so even climate activists these school
strikers protesting like Greta tun Berg
having to do that over Skype it's a lot
less in the public domain it's a lot
less on people's minds because
rightly there are other more pressing
issues to deal with now the corona virus
outbreak is actually changing the way we
think about a whole range of things
including how we treat nature intensive
farming has come in four particular
criticism many of many new viruses have
spread from animals to humans some say
that in growth that in growing vast
quantities of a single crop in
monocultures or stripping the
rainforests of its wood humanity is
laying the groundwork for outbreaks like
this one is that true adji are people
just using the current crisis to further
their agendas or is there indeed a
direct connection between say the
rainforest and the corona virus there's
a direct connection between human
activity encroaching on ecosystems and
the effects on pandemics whether that
was the case with this particular corona
virus is too early to tell there's some
suggestions that the virus spread
initially from bats through pangolins
and then to humans we know that the
center of the outbreak in Wuhan China
was in a wet market where you've got
lots of animals being traded sold
illegally for meat on top of each other
it's very easy to spread from animal to
animal now that can all accelerate and
what we're seeing clearly from calls
from ecologist calls from scientists to
protect these rainforests to protect
nature and even if we can't necessarily
link it to the current crisis to be
aware that this will help prevent future
pandemics I did narrow down from our
environment desks thank you very much ok
time now for your questions answered by
our science correspondents Derek
Williams locked away in his office at
home today we start with the weather
does hot weather help stop or slow the
virus many infectious endemic diseases
responds to weather conditions or have
seasons like flu which is most prevalent
in the northern hemisphere in the winter
time that's not just because it might
remain intact outside the body for
longer in the cold or the damp but also
because wintertime is when people tend
to group together in enclosed spaces
most of the most severe coronavirus
outbreaks so far have been in places
that were still in the midst of winter
but where spring is now on the way we
don't really know yet whether when
things heat up in the northern
hemisphere it'll slow the spread of
kovat 19:00 but there is reason for
cautious hope that it might related
coronaviruses have been shown to have
seasonality but the w-h-o has warned
that at this point we very much just
have to wait and see what's the lifespan
of the corona virus a study released a
few weeks ago in the New England Journal
of Medicine looked at exactly that
question and came up with some ballpark
figures at first looked at how long the
corona virus remained in the air and
found there were still viable levels of
it after three hours the researchers
also looked at materials like stainless
steel and plastic and found that the
virus survives on those surfaces for up
to three days on cardboard it only
remained viable for around 24 hours it's
important to say that those tests they
took place under strict laboratory
conditions so you can't really transfer
those results one to one in the real
world in all likelihood those are
probably pretty conservative estimates
and the virus won't survive that long in
real world conditions on those surfaces
but they do provide a kind of rule of
thumb
can the virus spread when money changes
hands paper banknotes and bills are not
all that different than surfaces like
cardboard so yes you can't expect the
virus to survive for a while on their
surfaces other studies have shown that
money does regularly collect and spread
other microorganisms in China at one
point early in the outbreak officials
were even disinfecting banknotes in an
effort to control the spread of kovat 19
so in theory yes money is a possible
vector for infection but but don't
forget that you can't catch the disease
through your skin the virus has to get
into your respiratory tract and it does
that by your hands when you touch your
face so if you avoid doing that and wash
your hands thoroughly after conducting
any monetary transactions it should be
an effective way to limit any risk now
before we go let's spare a thought for
our animal friends in zoos around the
world this Lynx seems happy to see some
humans again just like this ostrich
cheerfully welcoming the camera crew
here at the zoo as I'm she accidently
the ones who feel it the most are the
highly intelligent creatures like Apes
and parrots the sudden lack of
stimulation is a problem for them for us
it would be a bit like having our TVs
removed from our homes after all
visitors are a key source of their
entertainment entertainment for the tila
animals throughout the zoo seem to be
looking out for any human contact
others are becoming more intimate with
their fellow beasts birds in particular
are focusing more than usual on their
mates before they were often distracted
by visitors keepers say that once the
corona crisis is over they expect to see
a little baby boom
you